what if there's a million elon musks
very very weird
i don't know if i should tell you this
should i tell you a story all right
let's i'll tell you the story
all right so what do people do when they
go out to the desert right they always
take [ __ ] mushrooms or peyote or
whatever so i finally decided like you
know what [ __ ] this i'm gonna try it
so my buddy told me to only take like
four all right so in my head i'm like
okay that means i should take
six all right because he's trying to
ease me into this thing it's like i'm
only gonna do this once i'm never gonna
do it again i wanna [ __ ] see [ __ ]
talking to me right so i say to my wife
i'm gonna take six and she was like well
why would you take
six he told you to take four so i'm like
all right you're probably right you're
probably right
all right so the kids are in bed
it's a four-hour ride it's 10 o'clock at
night i'm like [ __ ] it i'm going in
right so i take this [ __ ]
one pill makes you nervous right so i
take the [ __ ]
and uh didn't take long like 40 minutes
later it hit me
it just kind of felt like i ate like a
[ __ ] pot cookie or something
and uh
i don't know there was a couple of times
like the toilet looked like it was
breathing
you know or like a painting kind of
looked like it was moving but other than
that i wasn't like seeing [ __ ]
seeing [ __ ] right which kind of bugged
me i was like [ __ ] i knew i should have
taken
six right but the whole time i was like
nauseous i was like what is this
is this like [ __ ] heroin like you
puke or something and uh
i don't know it was like it was all
right i didn't but i didn't like
trip i just kind of got into a weirder
sort of it felt like i ate weed or
something right
i know there's all these mushroom people
going like oh man uh
dude you shoulda because everybody know
what takes muslims like oh my god dude
and like i i understand myself and i
understand
like [ __ ] the universe and i'm one
with it
and i was looking at all people and just
feeling nothing but love
that didn't happen for me i think
because i've been facing all of these
[ __ ] things that i've been running
from
uh it kind of went the other way like
after i was done kind of like
[ __ ] like vibrating and stuff and i was
sort of coming down
uh i was left with this profound sense
of sadness and loneliness and i was even
thinking about people that i knew that
i knew loved me and i still was still
feeling that and i was like what the
[ __ ] is this
this is crazy right so whatever i went
to bed
and then the next morning when i woke up
i kind of i think i pieced it together
so what else man
we had a bunch of uh
uh my friend growing up he had down
syndrome right
uh but they never got the paperwork done
on him so he just
had it you know just freelance uh
he did because his mom was a drunk she
never got the papers done on her you
know
and she said he didn't even have it like
he has down syndrome
she's like no he don't he's irish but i
can't [ __ ]
irish nobody's that irish
that's like
that's like 700 percent irish can't do
everything maybe weed
we're going to do something do a little
weed smokes we we using that as bad as
everything else
sweet is a background substance
i mean you can smoke some herb and still
function
and you ain't crisp
but you'll function
nothing higher than weed though i made
that mistake one time i
i was at a party some guy gave me some
[ __ ] he's like here man take this
[ __ ] mushrooms
i took it i forgot all about it you know
then a couple days later i found that
[ __ ] in my pocket i'm thinking why not
because i'm thinking it's like weed some
background [ __ ]
i planned my whole day out like it was
weed
i'll chew this [ __ ] up then i go to the
barber shop get my hair cut and then
i'll see a movie
i chewed it up so far so good
then i was in a barber shop like an hour
later
and it's funny because i was just
thinking to myself this stuff sucks
tastes like athlete's foot
i feel sick but i'm not really high
then i looked in the mirror
i saw the barber's reflection man
it looked like it looked like a big
penis was cutting my hair
i freaked out i started talking to
myself
dave calm down you're on drugs
this is what drugs do okay you know
that there is no way
that a penis can cut hair
but i started freaking out man i just
couldn't take it anymore
i jumped out the chair half my hair was
cut i didn't care
i didn't i just gave a bob a handful of
money
it was weird the balls opened up anyway
i
ran home man i ran home as fast as i
could
it's tripping i looked at the clock it
was 242
i was like damn 242. i got a sober up
i've never been this high i had this
early
i took a shower i was still high
i said maybe music will do the trick
i listened to every cd i had
i was still high exercise
that's what i'll do i ran around the
block
four times still high took a nap
woke up [ __ ] up
i looked at the clock it was 2 43. i
said god
[Applause]
two of my friends and i went to a ranch
in fredericksburg texas and took what
terence
mckenna calls a heroic dose
five diagrams
let me tell you our third eye was
squeegee
quite cleanly
i'm glad they're against them
you know what happened when i took him i
laid in a field of green grass
for four hours going my god
i love everything
the heavens parted god looked down and
reigned
gifts of forgiveness
onto my being healing me on every level
psychically physically emotionally
and i realized our true nature is spirit
not body that we are eternal beings
and god's love is unconditional there's
nothing
we can ever do to change that it is only
our illusion that we are separate from
god or that we are alone in fact
the reality is we are one with god and
he loves us
now if that isn't a hazard to this
country
[Music]
[Applause]
industry when we realize we're all one
it's gonna [ __ ] up the economy the
economy that's
fake anyway which would be a real bomber
[Music]
ah what are we talking about let me get
back to this [ __ ] dude
oh y'all keeping secrets dude
you know them
okay you the villain huh i get you
voldemort i know what's up you
dark artists
trying to be all cavalier
so what else man
oh my brother tried to [ __ ] when we were
younger bro for his children
he did son you thought i forgot about
that [ __ ] dude
nah
unforgettable
if i can remember that [ __ ] my brother
tried to [ __ ] when he was younger
we wasn't gays or nothing we was
children and uh
he was he was seven i was five
and he just got early on set erections i
guess
and i guess he knew he could kind of he
was like a problem solver and he was
just trying to hide him in my ass a
little
you know he did bro but he wasn't gay
it was just children and uh
and he grew up he got three kids now man
he's a youth pastor he's a great man
it's extremely successful
but uh he used to yeah he got early
onset erections he got hard in the front
real early
and uh and he would try to [ __ ] me a
little bit
for about a year and a half at our house
but that's how all remember this that's
how i would stop him so
for my fourth birthday i got a bag of
jingle bells you know
and uh i got them engraved with my
initials on every one of them you know
it was a real special thing and uh
and i would just shake the bag when i
would get happy you know
and uh and at night though
like i would get under the sheets you
know and to make sure he wasn't trying
to you know
get my ass a little
because we shared a room i'll tell you
that i'm gonna tell you a crucial fact
dude
crucial [ __ ] fact bro investigators
y'all looking at like you want
information
we shared a room i [ __ ] forgot
i just remembered i was a pisces for
some reason uh
i am i am dude
uh you don't care little
gab uh so that's how i would keep him
off me at night i would hide under the
covers you know
and just you know and i would take the
little bag of jingle bells and i would
start at the bottom of my feet
and i put one on each side of the
[ __ ]
of my bed sheet going up you know all
the way up
you know like a little alarm system
you know all the way up to the top and
then i would just just sprinkle a couple
of jb's up here by my neck
and then if he tried to if i heard a
christmas sound that meant he was trying
to do sex